Прежде чем мы перейдем к другим вашим
прогнозам, я хочу понять, как
вы их делаете.  А
какой, по-вашему, наиболее важный
подход вы используете для оценки
прошлого, настоящего и будущего?  Как, например,
предсказать будущее?  Конечно.  Итак, в
моей прогностической модели есть три
основных элемента.  Хорошо.  Самое важное — это
теория игр.  Второй фактор – исторические
закономерности.  Третий вид — эстология.  Итак, я
объясню каждый пункт по порядку.
Хорошо.  Теория игр.  Хорошо.
Итак,
теория игр.  Раньше я много играл в
покер.  Техасский холдем покер.
А когда я играю в покер, это обычно
турнирный покер.  Так что у меня много свободного
времени.  Поэтому я трачу много времени на
анализ игры в метаигры.  Хорошо.
Кто эти люди?  Почему
они делают то, что делают?  И,
играя в покер, я обнаружил, что
в этой игре нет глупых игроков.
Все они рациональны, но у каждого свой
взгляд на то, как
следует играть в эту игру.  Таким образом,
мировоззрение определяет их стратегию, которая, в свою очередь,
определяет их действия.
А если уделить достаточно времени
анализу игрока, можно понять
всю его стратегию.  А
потом я понял, что
эту метафору можно применить к геополитике:
каждое национальное государство имеет своё
собственное мировоззрение, определяемое
его культурой, историей и
политической системой, и на основе
этого мировоззрения оно разрабатывает
стратегию взаимодействия с миром.
Иногда эти мировоззрения вступают
в конфликт друг с другом.  И вот,
когда вы начинаете понимать, что
мир не определяется универсальным
стандартом,
а скорее является гибким
, динамичным и открытым, и что каждый
игрок участвует в
игре с нулевой суммой, стремясь оптимизировать свои
преимущества в этой игре,
тогда мир обретает гораздо больше смысла.
Эм, но проблема в том, что для
правильного применения теории игр необходима
полная информация, верно?  Итак, вернёмся
к аналогии с покерным столом: если я
могу видеть карты всех игроков, то всё в порядке?  Если
я могу видеть мысли всех людей, то я
смогу точно предсказать, как они себя
поведут, верно?  Эм, но у вас нет
такой идеальной информации.
Можно лишь гадать.  И это
справедливо, и это еще более верно в
геополитике, потому что у вас нет
доступа к
лучшим умам страны.  Вы не знаете, вы не знаете,
кто лидеры.  Вы не
понимаете, как работает политическая система
.  Вы не понимаете эту
динамику.  Поэтому вам очень сложно
оценить их поведение.  Так что же я буду делать
дальше? Всё в порядке, у меня нет этой
идеальной информации.  На самом деле, у меня нет
большей части этой информации, но
могу ли я обратиться к истории и изучить
события, похожие на сегодняшние?  И
тогда смогу ли я провести аналогии между
прошлым и настоящим?
И это мне поможет.  Хорошо.  И
третье, на что я обращу внимание, это
эскейтология.  Хорошо.  А что такое эсквитология?
Вы хотите, чтобы я объяснил, что это такое,
или на все
100%?  Хорошо.  Конечно.  Хорошо.  Слово «эскетология»
происходит от греческого слова «escaton», что
означает «конец».  В буквальном смысле это означает
изучение конца.  Это означает, что
каждая религия имеет своё собственное
понимание
и теорию
того, как закончится мир или как мы
воссоединимся с Богом.
А эстология
часто
связана с самыми экстремальными
религиозными элементами.  А причина в том, что
эскейтология очень увлекательна.
Это как сценарий к фильму.  И кажется,
люди хотят это разыграть, потому что,
если вы посмотрите концовку, то увидите, что будет дальше?  Если вы
знаете, что Иисус может вернуться, если вы будете
совершать определённые действия ради определённых
целей, если всё сложится
воедино, если всё выровняется, и Иисус
вернётся, то это сделает вас гораздо
более решительными и мотивированными на
исполнение
этого пророчества.
Таким образом, пророчество превращается в план, и именно
поэтому эскетология
важна: люди, которые верят
в эту эскетологию, гораздо более
мотивированы,
энергичны и сплочены, чем другие
, а это значит, что у них больше
власти, чем у других людей.  Поэтому именно за этими
игроками стоит следить в этой
игре.  Таким образом, если вы посмотрите на то, что
происходит на Ближнем Востоке, вы можете
утверждать, что во многом это
обусловлено эскетологией, поскольку существуют
эти христианские сионисты, эти
религиозные евреи [фыркает], которые считают, что
манипулирование определенными событиями на Ближнем
Востоке путем провоцирования войны может привести к плачевным результатам.
По сути, вы возвестите о наступлении последних
времен.  Эм, для христианских сионистов
это означает восхищение и возвращение
Иисуса.  Для религиозных евреев это означает
пришествие Мессии, строительство
третьего храма и
наступление мессианской эры.  Хорошо?  Но
люди также не понимают, что
эзотерика — это не просто план,
это еще и скрытая история.
Причина в том, что у
нас очень мало письменной истории.
Возможно, еще со времен греков.  Хорошо.  Но
греки существуют уже, знаете ли, 3000 лет.
Так что, это не так уж и много.  Мы существуем
как минимум 10 000 лет.  Вы
возвращаетесь к наскальным рисункам ледникового периода
.  Хорошо?  Итак, мы уходим в далекое
прошлое.  У нас такой истории нет.  На
самом деле, у нас нет большей части нашей истории.
Таким образом, религия
берет обширную историю и аллегорически преобразует
ее в повествования, истории,
религиозные верования, которые отражают
суть этой истории.
Итак, если мы верим, что история повторяется
или в ней существует определенная закономерность
, то религия, по сути,
расшифровывает или раскрывает нам
эти закономерности истории.  Подумайте об
астрологии, верно?  Астрология пытается
раскрыть вам закономерности
движения звёзд, то, как затем
[фыркает] определяется
то, как разворачиваются события в реальном мире,
верно?  В этом смысле эскейтология очень похожа
на астрологию, поскольку это
не просто план.  Это
не просто пророчество, это еще и
скрытая схема того, как будут
развиваться события,
верно?  А если взглянуть на эсквитологию, то она в
основном посвящена упадку империй,
упадку цивилизации.
И такое случалось очень часто в
истории человечества.  А если взглянуть на то, что
происходит сегодня, с исторической
точки зрения, то это упадок
империй, упадок цивилизации.
Это почти как крах бронзового века
.  Таким образом, эскейтология предоставляет
вам довольно хорошую основу для понимания того, как всё это
будет развиваться.  Мне
кажется, что именно в части, посвященной технике игры на скейтборде,
многие перестают обращать внимание на вашу работу.
Они считают, что этот конспиролог, вот такой,
не имеет никакого смысла, утверждая,
что люди будут вести себя определенным образом,
исходя из представлений о конце света.  Можете привести мне очень
простой пример того, как если бы
мы с вами разделяли одни и те же навыки владения шпагой, это
привело бы к тому, что наши жизненные решения
изменились бы?  Можете привести пример
?
Конечно.  Хорошо.  Итак, давайте рассмотрим
наиболее распространенные в настоящее время техники плетения кос.  Хорошо.  Итак, начнём
с еврейской
эскетологии.
Евреи верят, что
они избранный народ,
любимый народ Бога, Яхве.
Кульминацией или вершиной
их цивилизации было царство царя Давида,
царство Давида, и
царь Соломон. Именно тогда царь
Соломон построил храм Соломона, который был
домом Божьим, и именно там Яхве
жил со своим народом.  Но,
к сожалению, еврейский народ не был
лоялен.  Они были неверны.  Поэтому они
начали жениться на иностранках, что
привело к появлению чужеземных богов.  И тогда Яхве разгневался
на неверность
иудеев.  Поэтому он ушел, и это
позволило таким захватчикам, как
вавилоняне и ассирийцы, завоевать
Иерусалим,
и в конечном итоге это привело к еврейской
диаспоре, к рассеянию евреев.
Но даже в условиях диаспоры они стремятся
вернуться в Иерусалим, чтобы воссоединиться со
своим Богом.  В еврейской традиции
раввины говорят еврейскому народу, что
когда Бог будет готов, когда еврейский
народ будет готов к этому воссоединению,
придёт Мессия.  Мессия вернет
еврейский народ в
землю обетованную.  Он построит государство
Израиль и вернется, он призовет Его
вернуться в Израиль, и он
построит третий храм, чтобы Бог
пришел. В конце концов, он встретится со своими
врагами в войне Гога, но он одержит
победу, и это положит начало
мессианской эре.  Поэтому наша главная обязанность как еврейского народа —
глубоко размышлять
о том, кто мы есть, заниматься духовной
алхимией, и как только мы вступим в долгий
процесс искупления
и как только наши сердца откроются Богу,
тогда Бог пошлет нам Мессию.  Поэтому будьте
хорошим человеком, ждите и будьте терпеливы.
Хорошо?  Итак, это стандартное,
общепринятое еврейское понимание.
[фыркает]
Но есть и такие экстремисты,
которые
считают, что это не в замысле Бога.
Божий замысел состоит в том, чтобы евреи доказали свою
любовь к Богу и своё
желание воссоединиться с Ним.  Поэтому именно
евреи должны первыми проявить себя,
прежде чем Бог пошлет своего Мессию.  А это
значит, что сначала нужно возродить и
восстановить государство Израиль.
Вы должны построить третий храм.  Вы
должны сражаться в войне Гога и Магога.  И
когда евреи сделали все, что могли,
весь мир, кажется,
объединился против евреев, потому что именно так мир и
поступает —
объединяется против евреев.  И когда
Бог видит, что Его народ находится в
крайней нужде, но видит, что Он
искупил себя, покаялся
и жаждет Божьего возмездия, тогда Бог
вмешается и исправит мир.  Именно тогда
наступит мессианская эра.  Но прежде вы должны принести
жертву, необходимую для того, чтобы
приветствовать Мессию и пришествие
Яхве.  Хорошо?  Так что вы можете видеть, как в
первой версии,
да, это интересно, но во
второй версии появляется некая
страсть, энергия, волнение, и кажется, что
разворачивается грандиозный исторический сценарий.  Всё это часть божественного плана Бога.
И я могу внести свой вклад в осуществление этого
божественного плана.  Так почему бы и нет?  Если я
действительно верен, если я действительно
верю в Бога,
если я хочу доказать свою достойность, разве
я не должен внести свой вклад в осуществление этого
плана?  Хорошо.  Итак,
вам понятна еврейская эстетика?  Да,
это определенно имеет смысл.  И я
хочу уточнить, что вы
не утверждаете, что эти э-э-э-эскетологии
обязательно реальны.  Вы утверждаете, что именно в это
верят люди.  Таким образом, это
меняет их поведение, и именно так
это используется для прогнозирования будущего.  Как
вы считаете, важно ли людям
понимать закон
конвергенции в эскетологическом контексте, чтобы понимать, как вы
предсказываете будущее?  Конечно.  Конечно.  Хорошо.
Итак, существуют разные,
разные техники скрещивания.  Хорошо.  Я только что
упомянул еврейскую эскейтологию, но есть и
другие.  Существует православная
эскветология.  Есть ещё католический.
Есть протестантская, есть
христианско-сионистская.  А вот и
мормонский вариант, понятно?  Есть масонская масонская
.  Существует множество различных
стилей эскетологии.
И что действительно интересно, так это то, что
в определенных точках они сходятся
, то есть выравниваются
.  Это означает, что это разные
религиозные традиции.
Повторюсь, речь идёт лишь о
меньшинстве, об этих экстремистах, верно?  Может быть,
1% от всей группы, понятно?  Но это
самые энергичные из них.  Они
наиболее сплочены.  Они самые
целеустремлённые, верно?  И если они
работают вместе над реализацией определённого
сценария, и если сценарий в
определённых моментах похож, то можно
быть уверенным, что всё так и произойдёт,
потому что в конечном итоге
мы — участники этого грандиозного
исторического повествования.  Таким образом, именно наши действия
определяют историю.  Ммм, если
просто посмотреть на определенные
точки схождения, то поразительно, насколько они совпадают.
Хорошо.  Таким образом, одной из главных точек соприкосновения является
восстановление государства
Израиль.  Это произошло в 1948 году.
Затем еще одной точкой соприкосновения стала война
и хаос на Ближнем Востоке, которые
происходят прямо сейчас.  Еще одной
точкой соприкосновения является строительство третьего
храма.  И вот в чем проблема:
сейчас мечеть Алексея,
третье по святости место в
мусульманском мире, расположена там, где
должен быть третий храм.   Таким
образом, для строительства третьего храма вам потребуется разрушить
третье по святости место в мире
.
Это в Иерусалиме?
Это.  Всё это происходит в Иерусалиме.  Да.  Да.
Эм [фыркает]
и так, эмм, если бы Серебряная мечеть
была разрушена, это спровоцировало бы
религиозную войну.  Но опять же, если эти
теории
действительно сильны и верны, то
все они сходятся во мнении, что на Ближнем Востоке разразится религиозная война,
которая в конечном итоге приведет к войне
Гога и Магога, в чем они также
сходятся.  Они также согласны, и это
действительно интересно, что Америка
не будет частью этого повествования,
верно?  Америка не принимает участия в событиях на
Ближнем Востоке.  Иными словами, все
они считают, что
Америка проиграет войну против Ирана,
отступит обратно в Северную Америку и будет
втянута в гражданскую войну.
Все они так считают.
Они также считают, что Китай
не будет участвовать в делах Ближнего Востока
и, вероятно,
отступит в свои границы и
замкнется в себе. Да, так что происходит
это сближение, и именно поэтому
я могу делать такие
прогнозы, потому что, если
они захотят вести себя таким образом, а
они влиятельные люди, то,
вероятно, добьются успеха.  Вы сделали ряд
прогнозов, и у меня есть несколько дат.
Какой ваш прогноз на 2027 год?  Конечно.
Хорошо.  Итак, давайте рассмотрим некоторые важные
события, происходящие прямо сейчас.
Хорошо.  Итак, в Иране идёт война,
которая, похоже, с каждым днём обостряется.
Эм, в ноябре состоятся промежуточные выборы,
и люди ожидают, что демократы одержат победу на выборах в
Палату представителей, в этом случае они,
вероятно, объявят импичмент Дональду Трампу.   Кроме того,
мы наблюдаем
фактически глобальный экономический коллапс,
потому что иранцы перекрыли
Гумусовый пролив,
и поэтому удобрения и нефть не
могут транспортироваться по всему миру.   Итак,
Ближний Восток обеспечивает
около 20% мировых
поставок нефти, и она также высокого качества,
которое остальной мир может
воспроизвести.
Эм, это всё очень насущные
проблемы прямо сейчас, верно?  Итак, мой
прогноз развития событий
таков: во-первых, я думаю, что война
между Соединенными Штатами и Ираном будет только
обостряться.  Съезда с дороги быть не может,
потому что, во-первых, Дональд Трамп рассматривает
эту войну в Иране как решающий фактор в достижении
своей информационную цель, о которой мы говорили
ранее.
Военно-промышленный комплекс,
Пентагон, военные, вступив в
войну, не отступают.
Понимаете, я имею в виду именно это
, это же человеческая природа, верно?
Это своего рода ошибка, связанная с издержками, когда вы
уже вложили так много в эту войну
и не собираетесь сказать: «Знаете
что, я и так уже достаточно потерял».  Я пойду домой
, да?  Вы идете в казино и
проигрываете миллион долларов.  Вы же
не собираетесь идти домой, проиграв
миллион долларов.  Она говорит: "Нет, нет,
нет. Моя удача ещё повернётся к нам лицом".
Верно?
А ещё, если я приду домой, жена будет
кричать на меня всю оставшуюся
жизнь.  Да ну это всё к черту.  Я останусь
здесь.  Верно?  Таким образом, несмотря на некоторые ошибки,
расширение масштабов миссии, Пентагон не
откажется от этой войны.  Ситуация будет только обостряться.   В
любом случае, на Ближний Восток перебрасываются десятки тысяч военнослужащих, верно?  Таким образом, все предпосылки
для масштабной эскалации налицо.
Хорошо?  Хорошо.  Так что вы увидите наземное
вторжение в Иран, и в этом случае это будет полная
неразбериха.
Я думаю, что утверждение о том, что Америка застрянет в этом положении на четыре года, звучит слишком
оптимистично.  Четыре года — это оптимистичный прогноз,
возможно, 10-20 лет.  Хорошо.  Итак, это
одно из предсказаний.  Ещё один прогноз заключается в том, что
промежуточные выборы пройдут не так, как
многие ожидают.  Я не говорю, что
их отменят, но я
говорю о том, что прямо сейчас Дональд Трамп
и республиканцы пытаются принять
так называемый закон о спасении Америки,
верно?  То есть, они хотят ввести
удостоверение личности для голосования.
Теперь демократы заявляют, что
удостоверение личности избирателя сродни подавлению избирательных прав.
А причина в том, что
если действуют законы об идентификации избирателей, то
на избирательных участках нужны сотрудники ICE (Иммиграционной и таможенной службы США), а мы знаем, как работает
ICE, верно? Поэтому мы можем предположить,
что
в ноябре будут иметь место запугивания, будут иметь место мошенничества, возможно,
также произойдет
отмена некоторых выборов.
Я не знаю, какими будут результаты промежуточных выборов
.  Но я скажу так: результаты
промежуточных выборов практически не имеют значения,
потому что вполне возможно, что
республиканцы сохранят контроль над
Палатой представителей и Сенатом, в этом случае
Дональд Трамп продолжит свою войну.
Также возможно, что демократы выдвинули
людей, которых называют «синими псами», — это представители
аппарата национальной безопасности, то есть люди,
которые являются демократическими.  Итак, это
люди из Ирландской республиканской армии (SIA), которые работают в Пентагоне,
и они поддержат эту войну.  Итак, они
приходят к власти и объявляют
импичмент Дональду Трампу, если он продолжит эту
войну.  Хорошо, но также возможно, что
демократы одержат полную победу и объявят импичмент
Дональду Трампу, и это
все изменит, потому что у него все еще есть власть, чтобы
продолжать эту войну до самого
конца, и если его подвергнут импичменту,
вы можете себе представить, что он станет еще
более решительным в этой войне.  Поэтому
я не знаю, какими будут результаты промежуточных выборов
.  Но я скажу, что всё произойдёт не так, как
люди ожидают.
Думаю, будет много сюрпризов,
и я также скажу, что это не изменит
ход этой войны.  Я думаю, что
траектория этой войны уже предопределена.
Хорошо.  Также отмечу, что к 2027 году у
вас уже должна быть разработана основа для
национального проекта.  Вполне
возможно, что они уже приняли
закон о создании национальной системы призыва
.  Или же возможно,
что некоторых людей уже призвали в армию
.  Думаю,
к 2027 году иммиграционная и таможенная служба (ICE) станет гораздо могущественнее,
чем многие себе представляют.  Мне кажется,
они хотят разместить Национальную гвардию во
всех крупных городах Америки, потому что
готовятся к экономическому
коллапсу.  Они готовятся к
финансовому краху.  Они готовятся
к национальному драфту.  Им понадобятся
правоохранительные органы и национальная гвардия во
всех крупных городах, особенно в
городах, где преобладают демократы, таких как Лос-Анджелес,
Бостон и Чикаго, где, как они ожидают,
сопротивление будет самым сильным.
К 2027 году все предпосылки для гражданской
войны должны быть уже созданы.  Эм, я
не имею в виду, собственно, две
армии, воюющие друг с другом, а скорее
общенациональное
недовольство, беспорядки, протесты и
восстания.  Хорошо.  Так что будут и
конфликты низкой интенсивности, но именно так будет
выглядеть гражданская война
в ближайшие несколько лет.  Эмм, значит,
мировая экономика должна была
рухнуть к тому времени, как это произошло бы круглосуточно.  Итак, JP Morgan
сообщает, что
к концу этого месяца в мире закончится нефть,
и это из-за закрытия пролива
.  Но проблема
мира в том, что люди привыкли к
эффективности, то есть к получению
ресурсов как можно дешевле и быстрее
.  Весь мир построен
вокруг эффективности,
однако проблема заключается в том, что
эффективность и устойчивость противоречат
друг другу.  Итак, в качестве примера рассматривается
система учета запасов «точно в срок», верно?  Таким образом,
компании не держат товарные запасы, потому что
не хотят нести их стоимость
.  Поэтому они используют системы поставок «точно в срок», то есть,
например,
товар будет храниться на складе всего
пару дней, прежде чем его отправят в
другое место.  Но что произойдет, если
возникнет затор
в сети поставок, например, при перемещении груза?   Тогда
вся ваша система
рухнет,
потому что запасов не хватит на
всех.  Люди ведь не запасаются предметами
первой необходимости впрок, правда?  Таким образом, этот кризис, который
мы наблюдаем в мировой экономике,
будет только усугубляться и
распространится на все аспекты жизни, где вы
подумаете: «Ну, я не буду водить машину или
летать на самолете в течение следующего года». Нет, нет, нет, так это
работает, дешевая энергия — это
основа всей современной глобальной
экономики.  Так что дело не только в
путешествиях, но и в еде, чувак.  Знаете,
вполне возможно, что им придётся начать
нормировать продукты питания.  Несколько дней назад
премьер-министр Австралии Албанезе и
премьер-министр Великобритании Курт Стеймер
начали обращаться к своим странам,
и, по сути, их мысль,
хотя и выражена очень тонко, заключалась в следующем:
пристегнитесь, ребята.  Хорошо?  Потому что прямо сейчас нас ждет
нехватка продовольствия.  Но
представьте, что будет, если введут
нормирование продуктов питания, верно?
Это мир, невообразимый для
большинства людей, но это мир с
ограниченными ресурсами.  Это
мир конфликтов из-за ресурсов, и
это мир, находящийся в переходном периоде, в состоянии
коллапса.
Так что, эмм, пристегнитесь.
Вы бы предсказали, что к концу
2027 года Аль-Акса будет разрушена?
Ага.  Хорошо.  Итак, давайте рассмотрим то, что нам
известно об Алексе на данный момент.  Хорошо.  Итак,
был один еврейский раввин, очень
известный в Израиле, но в июне прошлого года, во время
12-дневной войны между Израилем,
США и Ираном, он сказал, по сути:
«Ух ты, эта война была бы идеальной
возможностью для проведения операции под ложным флагом,
когда иранская ракета
пролетит над мечетью Алексея. Мы её разрушим
и свалим вину на иранцев, тогда
персы и арабы начнут
войну друг против друга, и мы сможем от души
посмеяться. Какой замечательный способ
разрешить конфликт на Ближнем
Востоке». Хорошо, это одно
доказательство. Другое доказательство — это
идея Красного Огня.
Евреи, механические евреи, хотят
восстановить храм Соломона, построить третий
храм. Но для этого нужно
освятить землю. То есть нужно
принести жертву Красного Огня. Но,
согласно Библии, Красный Огень должен
быть совершенным. И вот этот парень,
фермер из Техаса, потратил годы
и миллионы долларов
Он генетически модифицировал идеальных красных
елей, а затем отправил их в Израиль.
И как только они их
уничтожат, они смогут
принести жертву красных елей, а затем
построить Третий Храм. Хорошо,
сам Третий Храм уже спроектирован
и построен,
кирпичик за кирпичиком.
В Иерусалиме есть организация под названием Институт Храма, и
они уже построили Третий Храм,
но все, что они делают, это перемещают
Третий Храм с нынешнего места
на место мечети.
Так что это может произойти сразу же. Хорошо,
это еще одно доказательство. Кроме того,
мы знаем, что последние два года
под бывшей мечетью проводились археологические раскопки
.
Так что, если вы хотите контролировать снос,
верно? Ну, вы так и делаете.
Вы притворяетесь, что это археологические раскопки. Вы
закладываете взрывчатку под мечеть,
а затем притворяетесь, что это иранская
ракета, а затем взрываете
мечеть и обещаете, что...
Нет, мы этого не делали. Это
иранцы взорвали ее. А на
прошлой неделе Нетаньяху сказал, что иранская
ракета была очень близко к
мечети Александеру.  И он сказал: «О, знаете, это
было так близко, и существует большая
опасность, что иранцы взорвут
все эти святые места: церковь
Святой Вечери, западную стену,
мечеть».  Иранцы — это просто
безумцы.  Так что будьте осторожны.  «Это вполне может произойти».
Хорошо. Итак, все эти факторы
складываются воедино, и вы должны верить, что,
учитывая тот факт, что сейчас Израилем
управляют эти религиозные фанатики, учитывая
тот факт, что на протяжении десятилетий эти
религиозные фанатики в Америке,
христианские сионисты, поддерживали
Израиль, и учитывая тот факт, что эта война
предоставляет идеальный предлог
и оправдание для уничтожения мечети, они,
вероятно, что-то попытаются сделать. Хорошо. Но
я не могу сказать наверняка, это может быть 2027 год.
Это зависит от того, как будет развиваться война.
И еще, дело в том, что эти
религиозные люди верят в
астрологию. Они верят в
нумерологию. Хорошо. Так что, если бы
они это сделали, должен был бы быть
ритуал. Должно быть астрологическое
выравнивание.
Верно. Верно. Верно. Так что у них есть
планета, но у меня нет доступа
к этой информации, поэтому я не могу
вам сказать, но, вероятно, у них есть планета
. И они, вероятно, проведут ритуал,
связанный с провокацией, чтобы
уничтожить мечеть Исаака.  Это моя
догадка.
Эта часть меня действительно завораживает.
Думаю, мы затронем это позже в
интервью. Но что теоретически могло бы спровоцировать
разрушение
мечети Алака?
Верно. Так что, я думаю, они уже заранее
обозначили план, который заключается в том, что
они притворятся, будто это ракета.
Да. А затем они проведут контролируемый
подрыв мечети и
обвинят в этом иранцев. И в
этот момент война будет настолько запутанной,
потому что американцы ввели наземные
войска, и война бушует на нескольких
фронтах, где иранцы также
разрушают нефтеперерабатывающие заводы, эти
предприятия на Ближнем Востоке.
Весь мир, особенно Африка, находится в
ужасном
экономическом положении. Там
может возникнуть [фыркает] нехватка продовольствия в
Африке. В Африке может быть целая семья,
и поэтому весь мир как бы
отвлечен. Верно.
Верно. А потом мечеть Алака
взрывают, и люди думают: что? Что
было?  Что это? Что такое Алекс и мечеть?
Правильно. Потому что у людей не
хватает еды. На
улицах беспорядки. Продуктовые магазины
пусты.
Люди не думают: «Ну, у меня нет
работы,
мой банковский счет обнулился,
еды нет, и все
воюют друг с другом, кому какое дело,
кроме мечети?»
Потому что это было случайное
разрушение. Теоретически, вы думаете, мы
движемся к ядерной войне?
Я убежден, что
ядерное оружие не будет использовано в
этой войне, и причина в том, что, согласно
теории игр,
Иран,
Израиль и Соединенные Штаты не получат
никакой выгоды от использования тактического ядерного
оружия. Хорошо, давайте рассмотрим Иран. Хорошо, Иран
мог бы за три недели создать 10 ядерных
устройств, потому что у них есть уран,
и технология создания ядерного
оружия на самом деле является открытым исходным кодом. Вы можете
зайти в интернет и найти
эту информацию. Хорошо, это не так уж
сложно. Если Пакистан может создать ядерное
оружие, то и Иран может. Хорошо. Но
Иран этого делать не будет. И
причина  Почему для них так
важно сохранять моральное
превосходство? И
единственный способ проиграть эту войну — это
если начнут летать ядерные бомбы. Верно? У вас
есть 10 ядерных бомб.
Хорошо, вы можете уничтожить Израиль, но у
Америки есть тысячи ядерных боеголовок,
чтобы уничтожить вас, верно? Так что это
нестратегично. А иранцы
продемонстрировали, что они очень
стратегически и очень обдуманно
действуют. Они проявили большую
сдержанность в этой войне до сих пор. Хорошо.
Так что Иран не очень заинтересован в использовании
ядерного оружия. Вероятно, они
даже не хотят ядерного оружия. Хорошо.
Израиль получает все сразу, верно?
Потому что Израиль пытается реализовать «
Большой израильский проект». Он пытается
контролировать Ближний Восток. Поэтому ему нужно, чтобы
Америка и Иран уничтожили друг друга.
Сейчас они нацелились на
критически важную
гражданскую инфраструктуру Ирана, включая
опреснительные установки и
электростанции. Фактически, Дональд Трамп
пригрозил взорвать каждую
электростанцию ​​в Иране, если проиграет эту войну.  Война.
Недавно, кажется,
вчера американцы взорвали
гражданский мост. Хорошо. Так что по мере
эскалации войны американцы
взорвут каждый объект
критической гражданской инфраструктуры в Иране,
включая мосты, электростанции,
водохранилища, аварийные объекты. Ирану
потребуется несколько
лет, чтобы оправиться. Поэтому Иран не
будет представлять угрозу для Израиля в
долгосрочной перспективе. Хорошо? Америка
в какой-то момент отправит сухопутные войска в Иран, чтобы
выиграть эту войну, и это будет
для американцев трясиной. Они могут отправить
100 000, а могут и полмиллиона.
Кто знает? Но независимо от того, сколько
они отправят, они все равно
проиграют войну, потому что Иран слишком
велик, а иранцы гораздо, гораздо, гораздо более
решительны, верно? Так что это будет как
еще один Вьетнам, в котором американцы
будут вынуждены покинуть Ближний Восток, и
вся американская военная
инфраструктура перейдет в Израиль,
верно? Израиль станет доминирующей
державой на Ближнем Востоке.  Итак,
с точки зрения Израиля, вы
даже не хотите выиграть эту войну. Вы
даже не хотите в ней участвовать
. Вы просто хотите, чтобы Америка и Иран сражались как можно
дольше,
верно? Так зачем же использовать ядерное оружие?
Если вы Дональд Трамп, то
вы пытаетесь
восстановить Америку.
И, по сути,
вас не волнует,
что происходит на Ближнем Востоке. Выиграете
эту войну — отлично. Проиграете —
с этим я справлюсь. Вас больше волнует то,
что происходит в Америке. Вас волнует
использование призыва в армию. Вас волнует
ICE (Иммиграционная и таможенная служба США). Вас волнует
фальсификация выборов, чтобы укрепить свою
власть в Америке. Вот в чем суть
войны. Война стимулирует политические
преобразования.
И вот вчера Петр Гексев уволил трех
высокопоставленных генералов. Это можно сделать
во время войны, потому что они вам не подчиняются
. Они не выполняют приказы,
верно? Так что война — это мощный механизм
политических преобразований,
и именно на этом сосредоточен Дональд Трамп
. Верно?  Итак, вы хотите затянуть эту войну
как можно дольше, потому что это
даст вам больше власти. Верно? Верно. Так вот,
состоялась пресс-конференция между
Ламаром Залински и Дональдом Трампом,
и, по сути, репортер спросил Залински: «
Эй, когда вы собираетесь уйти в отставку?
Как долго вы были президентом?» А тот ответил: «
Ну, мы воюем, поэтому мы
приостановили действие конституции». И Дональд
Трамп сказал: «Вы действительно можете это сделать».
И Залински ответил ему: «О, да, вам
это нравится, не так ли?»
Верно. Так что он телеграфирует вам о
своих намерениях. Они не шутят.
Верно. Чем дольше длится эта война
, чем больше Америка
погрязла в ближневосточном конфликте, тем больше
выгоды получает Дональд Трамп в политическом и
личном плане. Так зачем ему использовать ядерное
оружие?
Профессор Джанг, многое из того, что вы
предсказываете, обусловлено экономикой. Итак,
прежде чем мы перейдем к вашему следующему важному
предсказанию,
вы сказали, что деньги — это алхимия, используемая
элитой для порабощения нас. Конечно. Как
вы думаете, почему?  Потребительство — это
совершенство рабства, и почему вы считаете
деньги алхимией?
Хорошо. Ладно. Итак, это действительно
сложный вопрос. Хорошо. Я хочу
представить двух философов, чтобы помочь нам
структурировать наше обсуждение. Первый — это
Мануэль Кант. Мануэль Кант говорит,
что объективной реальности не существует.
Всё — творение нашего
воображения. Верно? Он различает
понятия «нана» и «феномен».
Номина — это вещи сами по себе.
Феномен — это вещи для нас. И
поэтому то, что мы делаем каждый день, — это
участвуем в реальности. Мы создаём
реальность, потому что фильтруем реальность, используя
время и пространство. Таким образом, время и пространство существуют
для нас. Они — это то, что называется
эго. Но время и пространство на самом деле не
существуют вне нас. И поэтому очень
важно
понимать, что реальность — это
галлюцинация. Это коллективное
творение. Поэтому чем бы мы ни представляли себе реальность
, реальность ею и становится. Хорошо.
Это первая идея. Вторая идея — это
пещера Платона. В своей книге «
Республика» Платон пишет о...
Аллегория пещеры. Представьте себе
пещеру, в которой живут около миллиона
человек. Все они
выстроились по одному у стены.
Хорошо? Они прикованы к стене цепями,
их шеи скованы.
Они даже не могут пошевелить шеями, чтобы
оглядеться. Они могут только смотреть
прямо
на стену.
А позади них находятся люди.
Платон так и не уточняет, кто они
. На самом деле неважно, кто они,
но они делают следующее:
позади них горит огонь, они берут марионеток и
отражают их на
стене. И поэтому мы видим только
стену, верно? Мы видим эти
тени и думаем, что это
сама реальность. Хорошо, мы знаем лучше.
Мы с вами знаем лучше, но люди
внутри пещеры, потому что они никогда не
были снаружи, никогда не видели
солнечного света, не понимают
концепцию теней. Поэтому они думают, что
тени — это сама реальность. И поэтому
они дают этим теням имена.
Тени. Из
этих теней создаются истории.
Из этих теней создается религия.
Таким образом, эти тени — это способ
структурировать, направлять и фокусировать наше
внимание.
И в нашем мире деньги — это то же самое.
Хорошо, деньги — это алхимия. Они не существуют
вне нас. Они существуют только потому, что мы
верим, что они имеют ценность. Они имеют ценность.
Итак, вопрос:
как мы пришли к этой системе? Как
эта система была создана? Что ж, хотите верьте, хотите
нет, но долгое время деньги
не были проблемой для людей. Например,
давайте обратимся к викингам. Если вы
викинг, вы большую часть
времени занимались земледелием или рыболовством, но время от времени
вы и ваши друзья собирались
вместе и ходили в ирландские
или английские деревни ради забавы.
Хорошо. Вы нацеливались на
монастыри, потому что в монастырях
было много золота.
Они печатали книги, и на
обложках книг было много...
Золото, особенно Библии. А потом они
забирали это золото и, возможно, продавали его.
Они могли захватывать рабов и
продавать их османам или
банде «Бизон», кому угодно. Понятно? Таким образом,
они зарабатывали много денег на этих
набегах. Как только они возвращались домой,
они тратили все эти деньги на пир для
общины. И вот так
люди буквально тратили свои деньги. Они
не копили их, потому что в этом не было
смысла. Верно.
Верно. Я имею в виду, вы могли бы
копить деньги, выкопав яму и
закопав все золото в землю,
но зачем это делать?
Это было бессмысленно.
Вас заботила ваша репутация
среди сверстников. Вас заботило
сообщество. Вас заботило
оставить наследие, память. И
память была не в деньгах. Память
была в историях. И поэтому они
ходили и грабили эти ирландские деревни и
эти британские деревни. Не потому, что
им нужно было золото. Золото было полезно.
Но что было для них еще полезнее, так
это истории.  Они могли рассказывать
своим друзьям о том, как они отправились туда,
убили множество людей и
совершили все эти невероятные поступки.
Вот что для них значило, так это их социальная ценность,
верно? Они любили сидеть
в своих длинных домах в холодную
зиму, у камина, и
рассказывать друг другу истории о
великом герое, который отправился в
Исландию, основал там колонию, а
потом умер по какой-то глупой
причине. Хорошо. Но у них были все эти
замечательные истории, и они до сих пор у нас есть
. Эти саги, верно?
[фыркает] Северные саги. И
знаете, это чудесные истории, и именно так
большинство людей живут свою жизнь
в истории человечества. Это изменилось в очень
конкретный момент истории человечества.
1694 год. Хорошо. 1694 год.
Причина в том, что Банк Англии
был основан в Англии в это
время. 1688 год — это так называемая
Славная революция. Так что представьте себе
Славную революцию как союз
двух протестантских империй,
Британской и  Голландская республика. В
тот период истории Голландская республика
была самой богатой державой в мире,
потому что контролировала торговлю пряностями
на Дальнем Востоке. Их корабли отправлялись на
Дальний Восток, собирали пряности, а затем
продавали их по всей Европе.
Пряности в то время были
самым ценным товаром в мире,
потому что они улучшали вкус еды,
верно? Золото использовать нельзя было,
но можно было. Поэтому пряности были
самым ценным товаром в
мире, особенно с Дальнего Востока.
Корица, мускатный орех, черный перец — вот такие
вещи.
Проблема Голландской республики заключалась в том,
что она находилась в глубине континента. Поэтому Католическая
империя, Католическая церковь,
испанцы могли прийти и завоевать её,
верно? Поэтому существовала реальная тревога:
они накапливали огромное
богатство, но им нужно было его защищать
. Поэтому они решили, что лучшее
место для хранения богатства — это остров,
куда никто не сможет вторгнуться. Этой страной, конечно же,
была Англия. Таким образом, возник этот
союз между Англией и Голландской
республикой. И теперь вопрос:
хорошо, у вас есть всё это богатство, накопленное...
Голландцы, но как это использовать? Как
это хранить? Как, э-э, создавать больше
богатства? Хорошо. И подождите, извините,
я упустил очень важный момент.
Раньше никого не волновало
создание богатства. В этом
не было смысла. Но вдруг
голландцы стали заботиться о создании богатства.
Причина в том, что существовали заветы. Хорошо.
Итак, до протестантской Реформации,
э-э, все в Европе были католиками и
верили, что если я буду делать добрые
дела, если буду повиноваться церкви, я попаду в
рай. Это называется
оправданием делами. Если я просто буду повиноваться
католической церкви, я смогу попасть в
рай. Но со временем католическая
церковь начала злоупотреблять этой привилегией. Она
стала очень коррумпированной. Она начала продавать
людям привилегии. Знаете, если вы
были ужасным, ужасным
аристократом, э-э, совершали всевозможные
грехи, но у вас было много денег,
католическая церковь говорила: «О,
это нормально».  «Мы вас простим».
И это индульгенции.
Именно так. Слово «индульгенция». Это
верно. Идея
индульгенций в том, что вы не попадаете в
ад. Вы попадаете в чистилище, а затем
в рай, потому что
технически, если вы совершили
столько зла в мире, вы должны попасть
в ад. Хорошо. Но если вы заплатили
Католической церкви достаточно денег за
индульгенцию, то, э-э, вы могли попасть в
чистилище и сократить свое пребывание там.
И, э-э, чтобы построить эти
монументальные церкви, такие как базилика Святого Петра
, церковь продавала
индульгенции направо и налево всем желающим. Хорошо,
это была масштабная коррупционная афера.
И, очевидно, многие люди были
очень возмущены этим. И поэтому такие люди, как
Мартин Лютер и Джон Кальвин,
начали сомневаться в авторитете
церкви. И их главный
теологический спор заключался в том, что вы не должны иметь возможности
попасть в рай.  Просто потому, что у вас
есть деньги или вы подкупили
священника, вы должны попасть в рай, потому что у
вас есть вера. Но тогда возникает вопрос:
как доказать свою
веру?
И тогда Джон Кальвин предложил идею
двойного предопределения. Идея
двойного предопределения заключается в том, что в
начале времен, до того, как Бог
что-либо создал, он определил, кто
попадет в рай, а кто в ад.
Это и есть двойное предопределение. Поэтому
не имело значения, подчиняетесь ли вы
Католической Церкви, у
Католической Церкви не было никакой власти над
вами. Поэтому просто игнорируйте ее и сосредоточьтесь на своем
собственном вечном спасении. Верно? Верно? Но
тогда возникает вопрос: как
узнать, что вы один из
избранных? Потому что вы успешны в
жизни благодаря своему богатству. Чем больше
богатства вы зарабатываете, тем больше вы знаете,
что Бог вам благоволит. Но
важно было не тратить это богатство,
потому что тогда вы показываете свою похоть,
свою греховность, верно? Это создает
очень сложную психологию, когда вы
стремитесь заработать как
можно больше денег, но не можете потратить ни копейки.
Потому что вы не хотите показывать свою
греховность,
и именно это привело к современной
финансовой системе, верно? Потому что теперь в
Голландской республике все кладут
деньги в банки, и поэтому Голландская
республика может забрать это богатство и
инвестировать его в другие места, хорошо? И
это привело к капитализму,
и почему богатство является именно
признаком того, что вы благоволите к Богу?
Итак, вопрос в том,
как доказать себе и другим, что вы один из избранных
?
И ответ — через ваш
успех, потому что в наше время
все верят в Бога и
все верят, что Бог — источник
вашей удачи.
Верно.
Верно. Так что, если у вас хорошая жизнь, это
значит, что вы были благочестивым человеком,
и Бог благоволит вам. Если вы стали очень
богатым человеком, это тоже показывает, что
Бог благоволит вам, верно? Так что богатство — это самый
ясный показатель того, что
вы хороший человек для общества, верно?
Потому что раньше все зависело от умения
рассказывать истории, насколько хорошим
рассказчиком вы были? Теперь все зависит от
богатства. Насколько хорошо вы...
Вы бизнесмен? Верно. Верно.
Да. Да. Да. Это имеет смысл. Я
думаю, это концепция
находчивости, потому что
утверждается, что люди на протяжении всей
истории не ценили деньги, но
всегда считали, что наличие ресурсов —
признак того, что вы благоволите к
богам. Хорошо, это имеет смысл.
Хорошо.
И они определяли ресурсы по-разному,
в зависимости от типа.
Верно.
Верно. Итак, у Голландской республики было все
это богатство. Она не могла его потратить, но если оно
просто останется в банке, все это золото
придет и украдет его. Хорошо. Поэтому
они перевели все это золото в Англию, у
которой был королевский флот, способный
защитить это золото. Хорошо. Но теперь
вопрос в том, как обеспечить, чтобы
это золото создавало еще больше богатства, потому что
создание богатства важно, чтобы показать, что
вы принадлежите к избранным, верно? Поэтому в
1694 году они создали так называемый
Банк Англии.
Идея Банка Англии
очень проста. Это был частный
банк. Хорошо? То есть, если вы положите это
золото в этот банк, это ваше золото.
Он частный, потому что у вас есть  Чтобы
доказать себе и Богу, что ты
богат, верно?
И дело в том, что
парламент,
национальное государство, будет занимать
у тебя деньги для финансирования войн,
потому что раньше войны велись
наемниками. Поэтому тебе нужно много
золота, много капитала.
И короли обычно занимали деньги у
купцов. Проблема в том, что
король мог умереть, король мог проиграть
войну, или король мог просто сказать: «
Мне не нужно тебе возвращать долг, потому что я
король, а ты нет», верно? Так что
существует реальный риск, когда ты даешь
деньги в долг королю. Но теперь, когда ты даешь
деньги в долг парламенту, это безопасно,
потому что каждый человек в стране
обязан вернуть долг,
независимо от того, насколько бедной становится эта страна
. Пока национальное государство
существует, пока у парламента
есть власть, парламент должен вернуть тебе долг
. Понятно? Итак, идея в том, что Банк
Англии обладает всем этим частным богатством и
теперь дает эти деньги, то, что мы называем
печатанием денег, парламенту в долг.  Для того
чтобы парламент мог финансировать общественные работы
, войны, всё что угодно
. Понятно? И это привело к
созданию Британской империи.
Проблема в том, что теперь парламенту
нужно расширять это богатство, а как
это сделать? Ну, нужно завоевывать другие
территории, верно? Нужно начинать войны,
и это привело к расширению
Британской империи. Это привело к
колонизации Индии. Это
привело к
опиумным войнам в Китае, где
Британия насильно навязывала наркотики китайскому
населению, потому что постоянно
ищут новые рынки для
извлечения богатства, и это
порождает идею транснационального
капитала. Хорошо. Первый принцип —
создание богатства ради самого
создания богатства. Никаких
других целей. Это не для того, чтобы сделать общество лучше. Это не для того, чтобы
сделать
мир лучше. Это не для того, чтобы улучшить положение
человечества. Это просто создание богатства, и это
всё, что их волнует
. И это номер один. Номер два —
это транснациональный характер, то есть их
больше всего волнует...  Движение ликвидного
капитала по всему миру. Поэтому, где бы ни появилась
возможность, они стремятся
переместить этот капитал. Примером, конечно, может служить
позолоченный век Америки, когда
страна стремительно индустриализировалась, и
поэтому лондонский Сити, Банк
Англии, перенаправил
в Америку значительную часть транзакционного капитала.
Однако проблема заключалась в том, что американцы
в то время ненавидели британцев и
транзакционный капитал, поскольку
считали его источником
всего зла.
Поэтому они поступили очень
умно: у них были агенты, которых
они лично отбирали для
продвижения транзакционного капитала в Америке.
Этими людьми были Джонни
Рокфеллер,
Эндрю Карнеги, коммодор Вандербильт.
Вот как они разбогатели,
верно? Подумайте об
этом. Как Джонни Рокфеллер начинал с
нуля. И перед смертью он
монополизировал всю нефтяную промышленность
Америки. Как он это сделал? Просто
посчитайте. Невозможно
монополизировать нефть целой страны.
Можно монополизировать, возможно,  Огайо
или Флорида. Конечно, я могу это понять.
Но когда вы монополизируете всю
Америку,
это смешно. Хорошо. И поэтому я думаю, что
лучшее логическое объяснение заключается в том, что
транснациональный капитал
увидел его потенциал, поддержал его
и предоставил финансирование для покупки всех
его конкурентов, что имеет наибольший
смысл, верно? [фыркает] Эмм, так вот
что делает транснациональный капитал.
Он заинтересован только в создании богатства.
Он перемещает капитал с места на
место. У него абсолютно нет лояльности к
нации, и он верит в открытые границы.
Он верит в... он видит религию как
угрозу. Он видит монархии как
угрозу. И большинство людей этого не понимают,
но транснациональный капитал также
финансировал создание марксизма.
Хорошо. В двух аспектах. Первый аспект заключается в том, что
если вы посмотрите на жизнь
Карла Маркса, то увидите, что его финансировал
Фридрих Энгельс. Отец Фридриха Энгельса
был промышленником. Так что это и есть
транснациональный капитал. И зачем им было
финансировать Карла Маркса? И Карл провел большую часть
своей жизни...  В Британии. Верно? Это
первый пример. Второй пример: если
вы посмотрите на большевиков, это была
экстремистская французская политическая партия в России,
которую никто не любил. Все считали
этих людей сумасшедшими,
фанатиками,
но у них был доступ к транснациональному
капиталу. Их финансировал Уолл-
стрит. И поэтому во время этой чертовой
революции
транснациональный капитал финансировал
их, чтобы они могли нанимать наемников
для участия в войне. Они могли подкупать
иностранные правительства, чтобы те не вмешивались.
Они могли платить генералам
белых армий, и именно так они выиграли
войну с помощью транснационального
капитала. Так что эта экономика между
капитализмом и коммунизмом — это
ложная диалектика. Она призвана обмануть
вас. В конечном счете, транснациональный
капитал заинтересован в поиске
лучших инвестиционных возможностей, и
большевики сделали Россию лучшей инвестиционной
возможностью для транснационального капитала.
Верно? Потому что раньше был
царь и православная церковь,
и обе они были против транснационального
капитала. Они видели в нем антихристианскую
систему.  Они до сих пор называют это
системой антихриста.
Вы хотите сказать, что коммунизм был
создан капиталистами?
Да, чтобы, так сказать, проложить путь для
проникновения транснационального
капитала в мир,
верно? Потому что кто против денег? Ну,
король противится транснациональному капиталу,
потому что он не хочет, чтобы его национальный
суверенитет был уничтожен, верно?
Короли противятся транснациональному капиталу. Кто
ещё противится транснациональному капиталу?
Религиозные люди, верно? Потому что они
видят в деньгах источник всего зла.
Ребята, давайте не будем сосредотачиваться на зарабатывании денег.
Давайте просто сосредоточимся на молитвах Богу,
на том, чтобы быть хорошими людьми,
верно? Итак, коммунизм,
коммунизм, считается
вершиной Просвещения, потому что он
ставит разум выше всего остального. Он
ставит разум выше Бога, страны
и короля. И ни одна другая философия
до этого этого не делала, верно? Таким образом, коммунизм был
решающим фактором в развитии и завоевании
транснационального капитала.
Была ли это, по сути, контролируемая оппозиция для них
?  Итак, транснациональный капитал
был создан как враг.
Люди продвигали капитализм, который, в свою
очередь, способствовал развитию транснационального капитала.
Хорошо. Итак, что нам нужно
понять: чтобы транснациональный капитал
победил, необходимо создать целое
мировоззрение, целую
религию или целую философию,
чтобы она могла проникнуть в ваш разум,
верно? Потому что, опять же, на протяжении большей части
истории человечества нас не волновали
деньги, нас волновало сообщество,
нас волновал наш статус в
обществе. Поэтому транснациональный капитал
не только спонсировал марксизм,
но и другие движения,
которые сыграли ключевую роль в создании мира, в котором
мы живем. Хорошо. Одним из таких
спонсируемых ими людей был Джон Локк, который
предположил, что частная собственность — это
неотъемлемое право, данное вам Богом.
И это было новшеством для того времени.
В тот период истории люди были
благочестивы и их не особо волновала
частная собственность. Их волновала
их вера, их
сообщество, их
отношения с Богом. Джон Локк
утверждает, что частная собственность — это то, что
дано вам Богом, и
поэтому она...  Он находится под защитой Бога.
Другая идея, которую он продвигал,
называлась империализмом, то есть,
вы можете познать только то, что
переживаете. И это опять же
радикально отличается от
религии, которая предполагает, что вы должны чувствовать Бога внутри
себя. И вокруг вас есть эти духи, святые
духи. А Джалоп говорит:
«Нет, нет, нет, нет, ребята».  У тебя просто
галлюцинации.  Вы заблуждаетесь.
Вещи существуют только тогда, когда ты можешь испытать
их на себе.  Нельзя просто так что-то себе представить
.  В это просто невозможно поверить
.  Вы же должны уметь это видеть
, верно?  И это подводит нас к
Дэвиду Юму, который продвигал идею
скептицизма, то есть, знаете
что?  Даже то, что вы видите, может быть
неправдой. Хорошо?
Вы должны скептически относиться ко
всему, во что верите, потому что многое из того, во что
вы верите, может быть просто продуктом
искусственного запоминания, а не отражением
самой реальности. Он приводит
пример: допустим, вы видели
10 000 белых лебедей. Теперь вы можете вывести
идею индукции о том, что все лебеди
белые. Но так ли это на самом деле? Нет,
это неправда, потому что есть и чёрные
лебеди. Не так много, но есть.
Это означает, что все знания
основаны на индукции,
верно? Потому что вы не можете
увидеть всех лебедей. Если вы видели 10 000
лебедей, и все они белые, вы должны
верить, что все лебеди белые.
Но это неправда, верно? Это
означает, что ваши индуктивные способности
очень ограничены.
Таким образом, Дэвид Юм ставит под сомнение сам
проект философии.
Он ставит под сомнение сам проект...
Просвещение
и наука. Хорошо. Допустим, Юм, а
затем Джереми Бентам, чья
идея такова: вы можете
знать только то, что переживаете, и
даже эти вещи, которые вы переживаете, вы
не можете знать как истинные. Поэтому вы не можете
апеллировать к универсальным принципам.
Так в чем же решение этого
кризиса?
Полезность. Если это полезно для вас, значит, это
хорошо. Что? Что полезно? Это доставляет
вам удовольствие, значит, это хорошо. Как это
узнать? Как узнать, что создание денег
хорошо? Потому что с помощью денег вы можете
покупать вещи, и покупка этих вещей доставляет
вам удовольствие. Следовательно, вы знаете, что это
хорошо. А затем от Джереми Бентама
идет Джон Милль, его протеже. И
Джон Стюарт Милль берет эту идею утилитаризма
и применяет ее ко всему обществу, то есть
как мы можем судить о том,
хороша ли социальная политика или нет,
потому что она полезна, потому что она апеллирует
к нашему чувству удовольствия. Следовательно,
феминизм хорош, потому что он приводит женщин
в общество. Следовательно,  Либерализм
хорош, потому что он расширяет возможности личности,
и все эти идеи вместе формируют
основу для современного общества.
Верно? Но опять же, важно то, что
эти идеи являются результатом
транснационального капитала и его стремления
контролировать саму реальность, наше восприятие
реальности, делая мир
более материалистичным, но делая
деньги главным организующим принципом
реальности, тогда как раньше это мог
быть Бог, любовь, семья или сообщество.